What's going on? Alan Drau here and in
today's video, I want to break down a
sales letter that I personally wrote in
collaboration with Daniel Thrasell for
his Adventures in Copy Land uh issue
number 33 where we talked about uh
e-commerce emails Daniel Thrasell style.
So, uh I actually wrote this sales
letter for a product that he allowed me
to uh sell to his list as a bonus level.
I did get his feedback on uh some of the
things in this sales letter, but overall
this is 98% my work, my approach. And so
I'm about to actually show you a Loom
video that I recorded to break down this
sales letter to help you write better
sales letters for yourself. That's the
context. So enjoy the video. I hope it
helps you a ton. And here we go. Hey,
what's going on? Alan Drau here. And in
this video, I'm going to actually break
down the flow sales letter that I wrote
in collaboration with the Daniel Thraso
Adventures in Copy Lane issue number 33
where we did this big drop and and it
was a great big success. It was a ton of
fun and I've had so many of my email
subscribers asking me like, did I
actually write this? Was this Daniel?
And so, yes, I did write this sales
letter. I did get some feedback from
Daniel. Overall, I wanted to walk
through some of the just the concepts,
the big idea, the structure that I
approached when writing this sales
letter. So that way you can take it when
you write your next email, your next
sales letter, and hopefully it's more
profitable, more fun, whatever it is.
So, I'm going to walk through. I'm not
going to read the whole thing. It's,
yeah, 22 pages. Uh, it's fun, but I'm
going to give you kind of some of the
big structures, some of the big elements
uh to think through. Okay. So when
writing this sales letter, before I ever
put pen to paper, there were two things
I really really had to solve. Uh the the
first thing is understanding the
audience. And the audience being that
okay, who are we going to sell this to?
We are going to sell this to Daniel's
Adventures and Copyland
subscribers, which are his most loyal,
dedicated people, including myself. I'm
an Adventures and Copland subscriber.
I've been on it for over a year. I've
paid a lot of money uh to Daniel's
Thrive Cart for lots of product of his.
So, I'm already in the mindset of the
customer. I understand the sales letters
that they like. I understand the
verbiage and the and the tonality and
the bombasticness that that Daniel has.
But it did drive me to go to, you know,
my phone. And I opened up my persuasive
page on on the phone, which is Daniel's
app, and I went through his sales uh his
sales course where he has all his sales
letters, a sales academia or academy,
something like that. I forgot. I forgot
how he says it. But anyh who, in that
he's got all his sales letters in there.
So, I went back and I read through
Daniel's sales letters quite a few times
so I can get my head uh in that writing
style. Okay. and and in his
bombasticness in his storytelling manner
and try and understand why is he saying
certain things that his audience is
responding to. Obviously, this works in
certain ways. So, I did try and envelop
myself in the Daniel Thrust style before
writing this sales letter, which
obviously is why so many people asked
me. I must have had 10 15 emails where
people were like, "Did you write this?
Did Daniel write this?" I'll take it as
a compliment. Uh but but it means I
gotten into the head of Daniel's
audience perfectly. And that's the first
thing you have to do, right? When
writing a sales letter, you have to get
in their world. You have to get in the
prospect's world and um and write from
their perspective. And I know that if I
got in Daniel's sales letter world, I
would get in his prospect's world
because they've he's already written all
kinds of letters like this for them. So
I knew if I studied that, I would get in
their world, no problem. And now again,
I'm part of the target audience, so
totally makes sense. So, let me walk
through some of the structural elements
here. Hey, I'm back. Listen, slight
interruption. I have a gift for you. If
you are enjoying this video, then go
ahead and click the link in the
description below to get my free
copywriting catalyst guide. 63 cash cow
copywriting tips that you can read in 90
seconds each or less to help you put
more cash in your pocket today writing
copy. Some of the tips that I put in
there are insanely valuable that I still
use and have used for the last four or
five years. So, enjoy. Go ahead and grab
it. Okay, back to the video. Actually,
the second thing that I had to figure
out was the big idea. The big idea is
like it goes back to like David Oglev's
like never write a word on the paper if
you don't have a big idea. And I pulled
up like a little article right here
that's like the David Oglev quote which
is basically like he's the original big
idea evangelist where he's like nothing
works without a big idea. And a big idea
is by answering these five questions.
Did it make me gasp when I first saw it?
Do I wish I thought of it myself? Is it
unique? Does it fit the strategy to
perfection? And could it be used for 30
years? Right. Um yeah, slightly vague,
right? slightly vague, but but taking
this will kind of help you help you find
a big idea in your writing. And so,
here's how I landed with the big idea.
The big idea of this sales letter, okay,
if you if you can't already tell, it
says it in the first line, the world's
first and only sales letter pleading you
to don't spend a single dollar on. And
then I walk through the insanely
profitable, easy to use, ultimate no BS
e-commerce email flows guide that has
literally shoved a
$32,182 commission check in my pocket.
Okay, here's the idea that I'm trying
that I'm trying to convey right off the
rip. This is an anti-sales letter. Okay?
What I'm actually trying to do is
convince you that this is not a sales
letter at all. I'm actually asking you
to not spend a single dollar. It's the
opposite of a sales letter. Okay? So,
when a sales letter, right, the a sales
letter could be a unique mechanism. It
could be a story angle. It could be
whatever the big idea ends up being. My
big idea is that this is a sales letter.
That's not a sales letter at all. Okay?
And so when I thought of that, it I hit
it. Did it make me gas when I was like,
"Yeah, it did." Because I was like, "Oh
man, that's genius. A sales letter that
isn't a sales letter at all." And it has
to be really genuine, right? It can't
just be like, "Oh, don't buy anything."
Reverse psychology. No, this was like
100% genuine. I'll tell you how I got
there. Did I wish I have thought of it?
Yes. If somebody had have written that
idea, I'd have been pissed that I hadn't
have written it. And then is it unique?
I've never seen it. You've tell me if
anybody else has seen it. I've never
seen a genuine anti-sales letter, right?
Everybody genuinely does want you to buy
at the end, but I was not comfortable
selling this product. And so, it was
very real. That's and I'll dive more
into that. Does it fit the strategy to
perfection? Yes, because sell by repel
is going to make people want to buy more
even though I don't want them to buy,
but but we're selling a product, so I
guess I should want them to buy, right?
Like it does. It fits the strategy to
perfection. Could it be used for 30
years? I don't know. That one I don't
know. Could it be used for 30? I bet it
works. I bet this reverse psychology
does work in 30 years. Okay. So, that
was my big idea. And the big idea came
from the product that we were selling.
The product we were selling is um Claio
Flows handwritten templates.
Handwritten, right? Like it's on a
computer. Okay? It's there. It's not
handwritten, but they're Clavio
templates that I personally use for my
clients in the ecom space. Okay? And so,
it's copy that I'm currently using to
make a lot of money for myself from my
clients. And so, do I really want to
like give away my copy and my templates
that I'm currently using to make money
for, you know, 300 bucks and I'm making
thousands of dollars every month for my
client. Do I really want to give that
away? No. I'm actually I was very
uncomfortable selling this. I was like,
you know what? No, I really make a lot
of money doing this and so I I don't
know if I want to sell this product and
that's where the idea came from was like
I was already uncomfortable selling the
product from the beginning. It was
genuine. It was emotional. I didn't want
to do it. Um but then like I had sat
with it and and I tell the story in this
sales letter was like the reason that I
ended up doing it is because I'm a
really big Danielle fan. It was a dream
to be able to collaborate with him. all
this stuff. I tell it in the sales
letter, which is reason why copy, right?
I have reason why copy in there. But
anywh who, that's the big idea. That's
the big idea. If you nail target
audience and big idea, 80% of the letter
is written for you. So even though I
just spent seven minutes talking about
the the big idea and getting in the
target audience's head, and I haven't
like broke down a single word yet. Um,
if you do that, you'll nail a sales
letter uh 10 times more than anybody
else will nail a sales letter. So that's
that's what you actually need to know.
Okay, so that's pretty much how I came
with the headline is the world's first
and only sales letter sales letter
pleading you to don't spend a single
dollar um on basically the this very Ben
Settle style, you know, huge red font,
blah blah blah. The strikethrough. Okay,
so that's the reverse psychology part.
Somebody else asked me about this. Uh
why why did I strike this through? It's
because I'm trying not to sell you and
I'm being funny that I am selling you on
not selling you. So, a strikethrough is
like thoughts in my head that I didn't
want you to hear, but I'm actually
putting it as a comedy piece. So, this
insanely profitable and easy to use.
That's the copywriter side trying to
sell you, but I'm actually crossing that
out because I'm not trying to sell you.
That's why I did the strikethrough,
right? Here's the product. Ultimate No
BS e-commerce email flows guide. It
rolls right off the tongue, right? Like,
listen, I had I had like a day to name
this product. I didn't even know I was
going to package it, so I just gave it
the clearest name I could give it. uh
that has literally shoved a $32,000 one
$32,182 commission check in my pocket.
So that's proof, right? That's proof. So
so so proof and prom, it's not a promise
because I don't actually promise that
for you. The but this is profitable and
easy to use, right? Simplicity. Uh
that's the promise is that it's
profitable and easy to use. And then
that's the proof, right? So you do want
to have proof in your headline. Promise
proof. Promise proof. Great headline.
Okay? This is just attention and then
this is promise proof. All right, this
is very John Carlton style. You want to
grab their attention, slippery slope,
and then you want to make some sort of
promise proof. That's why I like this
like eyebrow copy, attentiongrabbing
headline, and then like that. It's this
is called the deck. Um, so the deck
headline right here is the promise and
proof. Okay? And I kind of inject the
product here as well. Okay? So that's
that's kind of the big way to set this
up. This is a good setup, by the way.
You could take this with with anything.
I love the little teasy eyebrow copy um
you know headline promise proof over
here. It's gonna it's going to be really
really good. So the stronger your proof
the better, right? The keep the promise
and proof thing in mind that the bigger
your promise the bigger your proof has
to be. And so my promise is not really
big. Okay, this insanely profitable and
easy to use, that's not like a huge
promise, but the proof is really huge.
And that's kind of the kicker, right?
The the the fact that the proof is
really really big. like a $32,000
commission check. That's pretty freaking
big. Um, at least to me. I know some of
you guys may be, you know, killing it
more than that, but kudos to you. All
right, so that's kind of the the
structure of the beginning. I did add a
picture because it adds humanity and uh,
statistically links under pictures get
clicked far more than just random links
or buttons or anything like that. So, I
don't know why, but it is. I read it in
tons of copywriting books. I've used it.
I've tested it. It does work. So, I
added a picture because it's me. So,
Daniel's pitching me to his email list
and his email list is landing here. They
might not know me by the time they click
this. Maybe they didn't watch the videos
or anything like that. So, I wanted them
to meet me and see that. I intentionally
did pick a picture of me wearing an
email players hat from Ben Settle
because again, I'm looking for
credibility and proof. These guys don't
know me. These people don't know me. Um,
and so I'm looking for ways to inject
proof in here. So you can't see it a
ton, but it is a subtle nod like, "Oh,
Allan, this guy is wearing an email
players hat. Email players is Ben
Settle. How did he get that right?"
Like, who is this guy that he knows Ben
Settle? That he knows Thrust, right? I'm
trying to use social proof as much as
possible to get them to trust me quickly
so that way they can read the sales
letter. Okay, this is the link you
should not click, right? Matches the
headline, all this stuff. I did put this
under here just simply because um uh we
were selling to a lot of people in
different countries, different browsers,
different internet things. So, for
whatever reason, Google was freaking out
on us or the click or anything like
that, then people could like manually
copy and paste this or type it in or
whatever. I just wanted to overcome all
bottlenecks
um and figured that out for my test. So,
uh classic salutation, dear copyriter,
because this is copywriter. U this is
where I do the intro. I'm not going to
walk through this a ton, but this is
where I do the intro where I tell them
that I I genuinely I'm not kidding. I
don't want to sell you this product.
Okay? And then I go into what is a
fictional story. Okay? This is a
fictional story where I say, "Well,
Daniel texts me, what's an insanely
valuable product that you can sell as a
bonus level to this month's ventures in
Copyland." That part is true. My instant
response is easy. My flow is template
for ecom brands, but I'm not going to do
that. This is where it gets fictional.
Like, this is where I start morphing the
story into what's not real. So why not?
So many reasons. Okay, here's why I
would not do it. And I say, and this is
where I'm actually starting to anchor
the value of the product. I actually,
this is part of the I write this as part
of the conversation with me and Daniel,
but what I'm actually doing is I'm
anchoring you, the reader, to understand
the value of the product. So you're
reading it as my conversation with
Daniel, but you're ingesting it as a
copywriter, and I'm actually selling you
here, right? So so many reasons why I
wouldn't do it. My agency charges $6 to
$10,000 to set up these flows. Value.
These flows take up 50 to 60% of my
clients total email revenue, which has
them thinking I'm some sort of revenue
angel sent from heaven. Value. Okay.
Just like tons of I've personally paid
off two cars with one commission check
from these flows. That's that check up
here. You're welcome, babe. My wife is
so excited that these cars are paid off.
And frankly, I have zero interest in
selling them to any other copywriter
until I've died or retired. Okay. Now
I'm also I'm further anchoring the story
into why these are valuable, why they
are rare, right? I'm creating urgency.
I'm creating
exclusivity. I'm pretty sure that's how
you say. And then I carry on with the
fictional story. Okay. I've never seen
anybody do a fictional sales letter
aside from the Jay Abraham, I sat down
at the piano, blah blah blah. And u but
that's not like bombastic fictional.
Daniel does the bombastic fictional. So,
I was like, what better way to do a
Daniel sales letter than to do a
bombastic fictional sales letter. So,
that's how I got the idea to do it
fictional. But, uh, you maybe you can't
tell at this point that it's fictional,
but it's about to become very obvious,
right? Daniel texts me this blah blah
blah. He does this smirking thing, which
is true to Daniel. He does do a lot of
smirking things. Why is he smirking? I
don't like this blah blah blah. And I'm
and I'm talking about it and he says,
"What if you just wrote some bullets?"
And I said, "No, no, no, no. I see where
this is going. I don't want to sell
them. I don't want to write bullets.
This is all fictional. We're going back
and forth. This is not real. This is me
writing a sales letter in a fictional
format. Okay. And then I say, and then
he's asking me to write the bullets.
Hey, I'll give you some free coaching if
you write the bullets. Why is he so
smirking? Okay. Coaching from Daniel
Thraso. Okay. Uh, for me, I'll copy Goat
that's worth thousands of dollars. And
with that kind of feedback, I could be
elevated to El Copy Grandmaster. I could
dethrone Daniel, Australia's number one
copywriter. Right? That's like something
he would say. So, this is how he's
convinced me to write bullets for a
product I don't want to sell. I'm
spiring. I like to add gifts. Let's make
it fun. Let's break up the copy a little
bit. Uh, let's let's have some images.
Well, how how the turntables have
turned, right? So, now I think I'm
tricking Daniel. The concept is that he
thinks he's tricking me into selling my
products. I'm tricking him into giving
me coaching so that I could be a better
copywriter. Okay. Okay. Deal. I'll write
these copies. Okay. And then that's my
excuse to inject copywriting bullets in
here. Okay. So my excuse to continue
selling you the reader is that Daniel
asked me to write bullets and now I'm
showing you the bullets that Daniel
asked me to write. Okay? And and so then
I inject bullets. So now as part of the
fictional story, I'm I'm putting these
bullets in. Now, the the part that uh
the part that I probably might change in
the future is I may put the bullets at
the bottom instead of in the middle of
the story. I don't know yet. Like
potentially people could skim over it.
People might not skim over it. But
either way, the bullets are really good.
You should you should read over these.
These are very I'm not going to read
over each bullet. Bullet itself is a
mastery of sales letter in its own. But
these are very
like John Carlton, Ben Settle, Clayton
Makepiece style bullets, okay? These are
like very direct response copyrightiting
style bullets. So these are not
necessarily like Daniel Thrasell style
bullets. Uh because candidly uh I am not
I'm not as like good at the bullets in
his world. Like that was one that's an
art in itself that I knew if I attempted
it, I didn't think I would nail it
nearly as well. Like I I knew I could
nail the fictional thing, but I didn't
want to halfass try Daniel Thrust style
bullets. Uh because those I didn't feel
as confident on to be honest. So I went
with like some John Carlton, Ben
Settlees, which Daniel has pulled a lot
of influence from John Carlton and Ben
Settle. So I knew it would still work. I
knew it would work because he still has
that influence in him. Um but it's
probably not how he would have written
these bullets to be honest. So you can
read through these bullets. I think
they're absolutely slightful. Like they
are so good to to be honest, but like
don't let me toot my own horn. Okay, so
anywh who uh this is where it gets even
more fictional where it becomes way more
obvious that this is clearly fictional.
Okay, so to this point you might not
actually know that it's fiction. You're
you're probably reading this and you're
like, "Oh, this is interesting. This is
fun." But you probably didn't know it's
fictional. This is where it becomes
obviously fictional, right? And so I
increased it, which is a skill set in
its own. When starting a fictional
story, you almost want to make it
believable. You almost want to make it
like, is this real? Is this not real?
This is I think it's real, right? And
then and then you can make a turning
point. This is my turning point where it
becomes obviously not real. All right.
So I do the thing where I say I text
Daniel my bullets. What do you think, my
man? Fantastic. Paris is on her way to
collect the flows. Collect the flows. A
knock on my door. It's Daniel's
assistant, Paris. You flew here from
Australia. I immediately bolt to my lacy
hard drive and pull it out from my
computer. You're not getting my freaking
flows. Paris, go back to Paris. Oh, I
don't mean to do it. So, obviously, it's
fictional. Clearly, she didn't just like
automatically fly to my fly to my door.
She's knocking on my door. I'm yelling
at her. Yield or I release the Mega
Lions. Mega lines. Not by my watch. I
shove the Lexi Drive in my jacket pocket
and immediately bolt towards the back
door. I use my thirdderee black belt
skills to fly in front, kick the back
door, bam. Right at this point, I'm
entertaining you. I'm just trying to
suck you into the sales letter where I
think this is just like absolutely
genius, super smart, like right. You're
like slippery slope, right? And you're
trying to think blah blah blah. Soon as
I kick down the door, you're not going
to believe who's standing there awaiting
my insanely badass arrival. None other
than pre newsletter guy, right? If
you're in Daniel's world, you completely
understand this. This is his character
that he made. the guy standing in the
back. Um, I I actually used chat GPT. I
screenshotted pre uh pre- newswsletter
guy and I said, "Can you make me
pre-newsletter guy laughing?" So, it's
not like perfect pre-newsletter guy, but
it's pretty freaking funny. Um, he puts
a gentle finger on his earpiece and
whispers, "Package acquired. Master
thrust over my dead freaking body. You
haven't acquired Jack Squad." Do you
guys like how I narrate this? This is
pretty funny. Uh, I bolt to the left and
immediately boom. Okay, here's another
pitch. Somebody just popped in here.
What? Yeah, let's buy this thing, bro.
Actually, it's closed. You can't buy
Jack
Squad. So, uh, boom. Next thing I know,
okay, here's a transition scene. Check
out this transition scene. I do have to
say this potentially might be one of the
most genius things I've ever done in a
sales letter. So the transition scene
here is that I actually transitioned the
scene into Daniel's parallel welcome
sequence, which by the way, if you are
in Daniel's world, you understand that
the parallel welcome sequence is like
something he invented. It's like utterly
famous to him. This parallel welcome
sequence is like has its own set of rave
reviews and all kinds of stuff like
that. So what I actually did was I
actually put
myself into the parallel welcome
sequence. So I said, "Boom. Next thing I
know, gasp. I open my eyes, panting
heavily. It's dark and I'm strapped to a
chair. Okay. Daniel wrote this copy in
his parallel welcome sequence. I copied
it and added it to my sales letter as if
I'm in the parallel welcome sequence
that you're reading. Okay? So, I tug on
my right arm. It won't budge. Same for
the left. My feet are stuck. I look
around. The room is dimly lit. Blah blah
blah blah blah. Okay. And then this is
where I shift the parallel welcome
sequence into this moment. A lacy hard
drive. my precious clavia flows
something about mega lines and then tap
tap tap I freeze blah blah blah it's
thrust right so now I'm at now I'm in
the parallel sequence but I've merged
the two stories parallel welcome
sequence sales letter flows I merged the
two so basically I took one of the most
famous stories he's ever told and I
injected it into my sales
letter that's pretty smart
right good luck thinking of that stuff
you can't think of that you couldn't you
couldn't I could have prompted a million
things. You'd have never thought of
that, but I thought of that. All right.
All right. Now, we're out of New Jersey.
Let's go back to the sales letter. Uh,
nice bullets, he mutters. Bullets? My
flows? What have you done with my flows?
Ha, they're up for sale. With an
insanely tight deadline, of course. I
don't know why I'm doing this. So,
obviously, I'm I'm anchoring that
there's a tight deadline. I'm anchoring
you that you should have some freaking
urgency to buy these flows, right? So,
I'm anchoring that for sale. I told you
this is how I make a living. And you're
selling them. Not only am I selling
them, you practically wrote the sales
page for me with those amazing bullets.
Having Daniel copy uh uh compliment me
in a fictional world with my amazing
bullets and just more authority to me
for absolutely no reason. I just wanted
to hear that. And then I'd throw the
gift. Dang it. Dang it. Okay, fine.
Whatever. Take my flows. Take my
livelihood. But I hope you sold them for
at for thousands of dollars at least.
I'm price anchoring. I'm price anchoring
because we're not selling them for
thousands of dollars, but they are worth
thousands of dollars. So, I'm trying to
price anchor you early so that way when
you see the price, you're not as
shocked. Okay. Thrust scoffs. I sold
them for what I sold them. What does
that even mean? We talking 3,000 at
least. Not even again. Price anchoring.
Uh, not even close. A tear, right?
2,000. I'm still price anchoring. I'm
prepping you for the price. Okay? Come
on. You know, I overd deliver massively
on anything that has my name on it.
2,000 would be way overd delivering. Do
you not recall my
$32,182 commission check that I got from
one flows crunch? I'm giving you the
proof uh through my price anchoring. I'm
not just saying $3,000 and $2,000 for
the sake of price anchoring. I'm saying
it to remind you of the proof that I
made a lot of freaking money from these
flows. So $3,000 would be completely
acceptable for you to buy this for.
Okay? I'm not just making some number
up. That's literally 10% of one
commission check I got. Okay? So that's
why I'm price anchoring them, of course.
That's why I decided to sell them for
$300. So now we price reveal, make it
big, we actually reveal the price. I
price anchored you the whole way. So
$300 should be nothing. At this point,
by the time you've heard of it, you're
like, "Yeah, no problem." Right. Right.
That's the That's the idea. Soon as he
fails to mutter a number bigger than
three mizzy finger figures, the the air
kicks out of my lung and I pass out
again. Right. GIF. And then I regain
slight consciousness. We talk a little
bit back and forth. We do it where he's
like, "I'm out. I'm only going to sell
for 24 hours." Blah blah blah. And then
I pivot a little bit into a pitch. Your
last chance to buy the ultimate sales
letter. Blah blah blah. I'll never sell
it again. No refunds. Completely written
with no videos. It's only for real
copyriters. You should not buy these. Do
not even think about buying. And then I
just make a really fun way to highlight
the link, right? You can click this and
it takes you to the Thrive card to
actually buy it. And I'm like, "No." And
then I give a note from Daniel. You have
until May 16th, 1159 to absolutely
purchase these clothes till they're gone
forever. and I'll release your purchase
elopico as if I'm still in prison in the
in the parallel welcome sequence. So all
that entertainment, all that fun, you
could buy it up here, you could buy it
down here, all things like that. And
then we pivot. So Daniel gave me some
feedback on how to pivot well, right?
Because over here is a lot of
entertainment, but you have to pivot
well. If you did, if you did not buy
these flows, you didn't get the
exclusive feedback from Daniel. And
that's okay. Sorry, you should have
bought the flows. But now, now I do this
thing where I actually pivot into more
sales mode. So, this is really fun
entertainment mode. Now, we actually
pivot into sales mode. Now, let me
transport you back to reality. Okay, so
we've been in fictional crazy world.
Now, let me transport you back to
reality. And and I do Daniel's little
reader character and and then I go into
real mode. I go into sales mode where I
say, obviously, I made most of this
story up. What's absolutely true is how
uncomfortable I am selling this product
to you at this price because what this
product is and then I start selling.
Okay? So this is where I actually do
real selling. I tell you about the
product, what you get with the product,
the benefit of the product, the proof of
the product. Okay? And then I give you
more proof of the product to clients
that I did. So now I'm selling proof,
proof, proof, proof. Okay? That's what
I'm doing. And then I tell you the
reason why. Okay? The reason why copy is
this is why I'm selling it at this price
at this time. And the reason why is uh
I'm justifying the price. Do you
understand why I'm very uncomfortable
selling to you for a measly $300? Okay,
I'm justifying the price. And that's and
then I'm giving you all the reason why
I'm actually doing it at this price
because I'm a big Daniel thrust fan.
I've personally invested $3,000 of my
own money to buying his products,
including 20 plus issues of AIC uh
Adventures in Copy Land. I've literally
done thrust style emails in the ecom
world. that's given me my entire career.
So, the opportunity to sell this to
Adventures in Copy Land with him is a
dream come true. Beyond honor. Not to
mention that when he said I could sell
something to his best customers would
become my customers, I knew I had to uh
build a package that would blow the
doors off that made me incredibly
nervous to build. Okay, so this is all
very real. This is all true. This is
there's no lies in here. In fact, I
think that's probably one of the best
ways to do a reason why is just tell the
truth. The truth is I'm a big Daniel
Thrust fan. I spent a lot of money with
him. I'm honored that he wanted to
collaborate with me. And I knew that if
I was going to be able to do something
and have an opportunity to sell
something to his best customers that I
wanted to sell the the best thing that I
could possibly sell and I knew that that
was this the flows, right? And so I also
told the truth here. I had zero
intention of ever creating it. This is
truly it. I don't want to sell this
again. Completely true that after we did
the sale, I didn't want to sell it to
anyone else ever again. I just don't I
didn't want to do it. Okay? I already I
was barely comfortable doing it the
first time, right? But I wanted to sell
it because I wanted to steal all his
customers and collaborate with him
really well. And so then I do here's
exactly what you get. Very Clayton make
piece. Just write it out. Okay. Here's
exactly what's inside. No sexy bullets.
Just like boom boom boom boom boom.
Here's everything you get. Okay. So
here's what's inside. And while we're at
it, I threw in another bonus. Okay. So
if you I've already got you to the point
where if you've read to this point,
you're like, "This is amazing. I can't
believe I'm getting this." Absolutely
true. Right? all this stuff. But then I
add another bonus just to make the offer
even better. Okay, this was this was
actually Daniel's idea was like, "Hey,
you should throw in another thing."
Which of course it was Daniel's idea cuz
he's like he wants to make everything
like juicy times 10. So, I threw in my
warmish client uh my my warmest client
acquisition system light, which is
basically it's it's a 30 minuteesque
video of my client acquisition system
that you could watch in 30 minutes and
understand how to cold outreach to ecom
clients immediately, which perfectly
goes with the flows, right? You get ecom
clients, you write flows for them. You
get ecom clients, you write flows for
them. So, they complement each other
perfectly. And it's a Loom video. It's
really helpful. I give you some uh
behind the scenes. I give you some
bullets behind it. And then I'm getting
close to the end of the sales letter
where I want to repel any of the trolls,
which I knew there weren't going to be
like a lot of just bad trolls or
anything like that cuz they're Daniel's
best customers. But at the end of the
day, I wanted to be very clear before
you buy this guide is completely written
and not sexy. Don't get mad at me if
you're like this is looks like a PDF. It
is a PDF, okay? It's a PDF. It's there's
no videos, there's no audio, there's no
sexy ebook designs. It's just a simple
guide that has some of the most valuable
information I've ever used in my life.
Okay? So, if that pisses you off, don't
buy it. I didn't want people to buy it
and then be like, "This is not
beautiful. There's no videos." Sorry.
Okay? I didn't even plan on making this
product. And candidly, the information
is good for itself. Um, I do not offer
refunds. I repeat, I do not offer
refunds. Don't call me with a refund.
Okay? Do not buy. If you if you are not
completely convinced that you want this,
don't buy it. And then please do not
share this content, right? To honor the
value and the integrity of this product.
Do not share what's inside. Don't tell
people about this, right? I already
didn't want to sell it, so I wanted to
get your pledge that you wouldn't do it.
So, just my three things here. Deadline,
link, sign off. Okay. And then the PS,
which is Daniel's extra bonus where he
said exclusive and highly valuable
15-minute video that he recorded for me
showing how to like how to make this
sales letter even better, which by the
way, the things that I said in this
video did not include the advice he gave
me to make it even better, right? So, so
that's an exclusive video that I am
personally honoring to his people
um that that did buy that and that got
that exclusive video. to this video. So,
there's feedback that even he had on my
sales letter that I did not talk about
today because I want to honor the
integrity of his advice and this um this
personal kickback. So, um yeah, I hope
this video was helpful on the sales
letter. I hope you got a lot of wisdom
from it. I think it's an incredibly
amazing sales letter. Okay, one of my
best
ever. Uh but I hope you enjoyed it. Let
me know if this was helpful. Uh and if
not, don't tell me. Don't leave a
comment. I don't care. But I appreciate
you. Thanks for watching. Uh and I'll
catch you on the next one.